همم انا ساقول يعني مشاهدات عينيه اكثر من
خمس اصوات انفجارات عنيفه جدا دوت قبل
حوالي ست او سبع دقائق اضافه ثانيه الى
يعني رايت بام العين دفاعات جويه تتصدى
لثلاثه صواريخ من الجهه الغربيه للعاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف فوق منطقه صوفيا القوات
الاوكرانيه اكدت انها تقوم بتصدي لضربات
صاروخيه ولكن اصوات الانفجارات التي سمعت
في كياب اربع او خمس انفجارات كانت عنيفه
جدا همم في ذلك همم يعني عمده رئيس بلديه
قال او يعني عبر التليجرام اكد ان هناك
انفجارات في العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف لم
يحدث طبيعه المراكز ولكن ما يتداول انه
مناطق او يعني الاحياء في وسط العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف هي التي تتعرض لضربات
صاروخيه في هذه الاسماء صوت هذا الدواء
محمد هل هو اللي اعتراض هذه الصواريخ ام
الصواريخ وصلت لاهدا هل من معلومات لا
يمكن تحديدها لان الصوت صوت انفجار
الصاروخ عندما يتم اعتراضه مشابه لصوت
يعني سقوط الصاروخ الى هدفه ولكن ما يعني
ما اتوقع الان هو ان هناك صاروخين او
ثلاثه صواريخ وصلت الى اهدافها في وسط
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف وايضا الدفاعات
الجويه ما رايته بعين يعني كنا نشاهد يعني
الدخله وانفجار في في الهواء فوق المنطقه
الغربيه للعاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف الدفاعات
الجويه اسقطت هذا ما رايته بعيني ثلاثه
صواريخ فوق المنطقه الغربيه للعاصمه
الاوكيه وهل تعلم محمد ان كانت هذه
المناطق للبنيه التحتيه اما هي الاهداف
تحديدا لهذه الصواريخ
يعني لم يتم تحديد مواقع سقوط الصواريخ
انسقطت او مواقع الاهداف عاده تتكتم
السلطات الاوكرانيه ولكن الحي يعني
الاصوات التي اتت من الحي وسط العاصمه
الاوكرانيا كيف هي وهو شينسكي ليون وهي
الاحياء التي تقع في عمق وسط العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف ربما تكون محطه الكهرباء
الرئيسيه في منطقه التي سبق ان تم
استهدافها قبل شهر من الان او في منطقه
هلاليون ايضا هناك محول محطات للبناء
التحتيه يعني الاصوات جاءت من تلك المناطق
وهو هناك يعني محطات للطاقه محطات للتدفئه
او ربما مراكز حكوميه تم استهدافه ولكن
حتى هذه اللحظه لم يستطيع الحصول على
معلومات الرسميه تؤكد مكان سقوط الصواريخ
انت سقطت او ان كانت هذه فقط للدفاعات
جويه استهدف او استطعت صواريخ ولكن
تحديدا
هل بالامكان ان تتحرك الكاميرا لتورينا
اين انت تتواجد وكيف هي الاوضاع
يعني انا الان حاليا في منطقه بالقرب من
وسط العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف يعني هناك
حركه ساير خجوله وهذه تعتبر منطقه سكنيه
وهل تتوقع الحكومه الاوكرانيه محمد المزيد
من الضربات الصاروخيه الروسيه بحلول نهايه
العام وراس السنه الجديد وما الى ذلك
حتى هذه اللحظه تم اطلاق اربع او ثلاثه
صاروخيه باتجاه المدن الاوكرانيه
الانفجارات التي حصلت الان هي من الرشقه
الاولى لانه عاده كان هناك 40 دقيقه الى
ساعه بين اتراك الصواريخ والوصول الصواريخ
الى اهدافها نحن نتوقع من خلال فتره 20
دقيقه سيكون هناك موجه اخرى وبعدها يعني
بعد حوالي 40 دقيقه ستكون هناك موجه ثالثه
بحسب موضوعنا ان هناك ثلاث
موجات اطلاق للصواريخ الروسيه باتجاه
المدن يعني
وكيف يتفاعل السكان هناك محمد هل لديك
معلومات ان كانهم في الملاج ام خارج
الملاج ما اوضاعهم
نعم يعني بعد في فتره التي يكون فيها
الانذار الجوي وهي الدقائق الاولى لاطلاق
الصواريخ يكون هناك فتره من 10 الى 20
دقيقه وهي فتره الخروج من المراكز
التجاريه او المنازل والتوجه الى الملاجئ
في الفتره الماضيه قبل استهداف العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف كان هناك تراخي في ااا نحن
نرى الان يعني الفرق الاسعاف والدفاع
المدني متجه
ه الى همم
حركه شرطه والدفاع مدني متجهه الى شركه
كهرباء هناك احد الصواريخ سقط في المنطقه
المقابله
يعني قبل حوالي شهرين كان هناك استخفاف من
سكان العاصمه الاوكرانيه كثير بالالتزام
بالدخول الى المدارس
كبير
الان يعني معظم محطات المترو في وسط
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف تحولت تلقائيا الى
مناشئ تاوي السكان